okay well there you go we're live what
rich welcome back that beer gets longer
every time and that beard is insane it's
only gonna get worse yeah what's the
vision there oh well I'm already having
dreams of shaving it's out I know if I'm
gonna last but the whole idea i started
i wanted to have like a mustache and
Bray and havoc like today it's my
eyeballs like do a Salvador Dali thing
some pictures and then shave it what
about the beard oh it comes part and
parcel oh you can use with you just do
the stache we're not on the beard and
okay I think just the stash is a little
too gay like it I don't like the way it
looks ah but it'll sting trim the beard
and no no no it's gotta be caveman it's
got to be real authentic fat this nah
caveman to the iphone but this isn't
this is this is like you know next
family thing for people who are watching
really what are you guys talking about
so as to talk about building some beers
here we go so update so what's going on
man here we go hit me so what what's
going on it's things are going well I
had a little breakdown and then a
breakthrough so that was good and then
we talked about that a little bit but I
was kind of like stopped for a little
while for a couple weeks and but I i
unleashed a few more personal videos
that don't really have anything to do
with my work or business or anything
like that or just kind of like some idea
some thoughts some shares and that's it
and I'm feeling good with that and I'm
just gonna for now go there actually I
have some ideas for more videos i just
wanted to discuss with you but that
that's pretty much what's been going on
so far anything that I'm missing no it's
so I mean update from last time you gave
up coffee tea and alcohol is that still
going o Allah yeah yeah I'm still there
no no coffee no tea no alcohol no smoke
no nothing complete okay okay cool yeah
I got one for excited about this the
last time we talked you were like you're
we should I wish you'd get like bring in
that clip you were
you're buzzing about your way you're
going to buzz but not being out of buzz
you know you were happy a bark 20 yeah
yeah no it's good and and we're talking
about doing two videos a week one kind
of two one kind of one kind of a tip /
question or one kind of interview and
now you had your reflection time um
what's what is the schedule look like
what kind of stuff do you want to create
what my schedule looks like Fortran well
you know what that that's the thing that
I was a [ __ ] for a long time just turn
off my phone here so jumpy look schedule
I've been running my youtube channel
like a hobby which is what it is for me
right now and so dedicated like a day
day and a half a week to it we're trying
to get everything rolling shoot all the
videos edit all of them sometimes it
takes me about a day or two to do all
that um and it needs more than that it
needs more than that amount of time to
be able to kind of get more videos and
better videos and and so I'm just trying
to figure out how I'm gonna allocate
that time well I'm running my business
and family and other things that I'm
doing so well I wanted to send father
pic what's that is it is that is that
the best plan is the plan that I need to
find more time to make this happen or I
need to find a way to you know a day and
a half is not nothing that I didn't half
a week is a good chunk of time you can
make a lot happen in a day and a half I
you know I shoot all my youtube videos
in yeah in you know usually two to three
hours and that's shooting 20 videos yeah
you can make you can make some magic
happen in a day and a half um but yeah
is that the plan or is it so it's like
I'm trying to kind of get where you're
at right now you try to find more time
spending on your channel or you're
trying to just maximize what you have
and be more effective with it well
ideally what I want to do is is figure
out a way to get much clearer with what
I'm doing with my channel so that I can
justify spending that kind of time on it
though I want to place
we get a vision for this is what i'm
going to do and commit to that and like
that really be in line with everything
i'm up to and where I work my goals are
so that I can focus on see I didn't have
for me is it may not be the same as it
is for you because it's pretty much me
doing the editing everything else so
your team around eats a lot more
organized at North so day in half but
it's a bit disorganized PP so it doesn't
doesn't get as much productivity and I
want to get a little more productive so
I want to get more organized and more
clear ok let's get clear right now well
this is it is us getting clear okay what
are we gonna do so um you know what I
had some ideas to maybe and this is
against just idea work let me create
some videos and tips around basics and
photography and video for people that
might want to get into it like it's not
necessarily anything that is having to
do with my business right now but
something that I can easily make videos
about I think it'd be interesting I'd
makes it be in my element to talk about
it not be kind of it be easy for me it's
something that I really know what people
get value-added out of it as something
to kind of start off with but you were
doing those so now really I was doing a
few of them around trying to get it to
the mine of what some of its in front of
the camera would need ok so what a
potential crime looking for someone who
can be in front of the camera would be
great like I know what I'm talk about
now is like something that a
photographer a video guy starting out
with want to know like what lenses to
use or the lighting and stuff like that
and is that like a ton of interest like
you are you give a burning passion to
teach this stuff ah you know whenever
whenever someone's asking those kind of
questions about they have a question by
the lens or about anything having to do
with like it's not something that I
would think of okay I really want to do
that but whenever anyone asks me
questions about that stuff it comes so
naturally and have so much fun
explaining to them that I think I might
have fun thing that game for a while so
okay so a couple fonts and
see where this goes yeah um you know you
were on my channel you when did you come
last week last week no two weeks ago
it's two weeks ago yeah two weeks ago uh
I think that's the best you've ever been
like you were you were relaxed you were
calm you had good stories and even
thinking back to some of the older stuff
that we've done you're getting a lot
more comfortable and and and through
that often a lot more value because if
you're nervous and you're searching for
words and you're not as confident in the
expression and so it's you lose
attention right so i really liked what
you're doing and and you've gotten a lot
better and i don't know that's because i
think honestly the videos that we did
together we're better than the ones that
you did recently on your channel like
you're part of it your comfort level
which is weird because I'm and most
people are usually better when they're
by themselves because there's nobody
else around them like we had a we had
lights and a cameraman and me and
rosanna and and most people would be
freaked out by that and get more nervous
but you were you were really good um
well but so it's been great to see your
progression in how you're getting better
I just found interesting that being with
somebody else you seem to be more
relaxed which is which is mulch of
different fine I don't know it's very it
is different which may be hey maybe do
more videos with other people too the
second thing and this is this one is
really important uh not that the first
one was it but this is really important
the types of videos that you make will
help you cultivate different audiences
right so the tips that you were
providing before four people in front of
the camera now you're going to start
attracting that kind of audience people
who want to be in front of the camera
right actors model a wall who ever right
if you switch it to behind the lens then
you're starting over and now building an
audience of photographers and you know
videographers and there may be some
overlap like a photographer my being
seen some of those tips to share with
their
I but the kinds of videos that you make
you're going to start attracting the
audience you're going to start getting
more and more of those people coming
along um just as a really example
somebody asked me about patents before
in my channel and you know I know a
little bit about patents but I'm not a
lawyer especially in the US right sure
what I knew about patents and in that
video people watched it and then I got
like ten more questions about patents
when people watching it so then I made a
few more patent videos and then that
just it just kept reading that I kept
getting all these questions about how do
i get my patent how much is a cost and
original or you know and i had to stop
answering patent questions because i was
what I'm not the biggest expert on it
into that's not what I wanted to be
known for right I had to mix it up more
um the same thing happened what i did a
video about cosmetics i did one
beautiful cosmetics and then people
started asking me about starting up
their own cosmetics company and then I
made a few more and it just started
going nuts and I don't want to be the
guy known for helping you build your
cosmetics company only right I wanted
the variety so more you're going to
start attracting out audience and is
that and it's great like if that's what
you love doing if that's the audience
that you want then you're totally on
track if you are doing this one day and
then doing this another day and then I
think the struggles has always been
consistency of getting similar kinds of
videos up together because they're from
all over the place so it makes it hard
to keep an audience so is that the
audience that you want you want
photographers you like educating and
that's a whole it's a whole different
business model um I met chase jarvis
yesterday he's found of Crater live
creativelive I think I said you I think
I sent you his youtube video his YouTube
channel um he basically trains what he
started off just training photographers
and he has these courses that he now
sells Satrina photography
first um and so that might evolve into
your business like now maybe you've
become the guy that photographers come
to for advice and maybe you talk about
your experience ladygaga and how nervous
you were how you got that deal and right
um so it's just what's the audience that
you want to go after right who are the
people that you want to connect with and
then you want to make videos for them
and there's nothing wrong with
experimenting every now and then and
throwing in a new one and you know
something that's off the wall yeah but
when you stop producing a certain kind
of video then you stop losing you start
losing on audience so the inspire stuff
you're creating the motivational videos
the fear series like you get a
subscriber because they love that fear
video they want to see more yeah they're
open to having other things right like
it's nothing wrong with infusing other
things in there but you they want to see
more of that fear stuff that you were
talking about it that just totally stops
then they're probably gonna unsubscribe
you're going to have a lot of churn in
your in your channels can be hard to get
it grown consistently so you want to get
clear is starting with who is the
audience that you want to go after and
then what's the content that you're
going to make for them what content can
you create on a consistent basis so that
you don't lose momentum is momentum is
so hard to build up and then once you
get it you don't want to lose it right
like you're finally getting comments and
likes and subscribers you don't want to
then lose it because you're you're you
weren't clear from the start I mean if
you're if you're switching your passion
if you don't like it anymore I'm not
saying go in and say I'm going to keep
doing this only because I have momentum
I hate doing these videos now and but
I'm going to force myself to do them
that's not a reason to do it but if you
can identify what you're passionate
about now like the stuff that you love
working on that that day and a half
doesn't feel like a chore that it
excites you and fills you with energy
um just trying to be consistent at that
yeah well that that's the mystery room I
got natural the wall that's why I'm kind
of hang around so what's happened with
the fear series is that is it gone is it
is dead no more interviews oh so far no
nothing right now it's gone gone oh yeah
yeah I'm getting a little you're getting
a coup yeah but that's okay I love my
ball okay um so yeah it's how on hold
like the success Diaries all that stuff
for me oh and it's it's not something
that I killed instead of a migrant duty
and this right now it's not a priority
haven't really make the effort to go and
shoot more than one developer so yeah
that's kind of that is I thought was
clear that for a while sometimes for
them come here of what it isn't really
want to do here is I'm I have fun doing
this for a while than that for a while
and so far it's a like I haven't really
found the thing that that's it I know
for sure is this thing or nothing else
and I'm on fire with it so kind of
playing around and I wonder if that
becomes like I'm searching for some kind
of consistent message in between it yeah
I mean inspire should be through
everything that you're doing and inspire
people to want to be better whether
you're answering a question about
photography or you're making a video
about fear because that's your one word
I'm wondering though if you're on a if
you're on a you know if you could put
into contacts like you're on a journey
like you're testing this stuff out and
I'm going to find yourself then that
that adds a little more context and a
little more stickiness between the
series so you know if you
and then you you you break it down right
like maybe a consistent part of what you
do is you talk about what you're doing
you giving me process no I'm shot that
and your experience together you like it
oh there you go boy that's what they
look like you're getting distracted by
shiny objects which distracted by shiny
object I wonder i'd love to have just
something on your channel that is
consistent and maybe it's you maybe it's
you telling um your story and like where
you're at every week maybe you're
checking in and saying you know I'm I'm
trying to figure out what I want to do
next and so I'm going to explore series
talking about photographers and gear and
behind the behind the camera stopped
because that's what I'm excited about
now and this is kind of what we do like
that's kind of part of it right when you
come on my channel this is the
behind-the-scenes what which is all
about but maybe that's something you put
on your channel and so I can follow
along your journey and chair and what
you're thinking about that and then then
the cuts to these other things make more
sense like I'm going to start a project
around fear because I'm scared of
whatever I'm scared of too many things I
don't want to kill my fear so here we go
and then you start these you know
six-week programs or whatever it is
however a lot you're feeling the vibe
for because I know you don't like to get
chained down like I know freedom and you
know breaking breaking through and being
a nomad is like is part of your thing
which is great and so a schedule can
sometimes be to like don't box me in
right don't put me in that box i'm just
going to break it because i want to but
just something to tie me along because I
follow you and I subscribe to your
channel because I know you and your
friend and I want to see you be
successful for any of the series if I
signed up for it I might then think of
what what is happening from jumping
around and the variety is okay I'm not
say
don't experiment don't have variety
variety is nice when there is some
consistency to write home I'm up you
know for example on my channel we're
just posting now about my Caribbean
vacation and the next thing I'm working
on now where's my you know I got I got
the GoPro with the microphone and I'm
filming Nina wanted to do a 30-day
weight loss challenge because we came
home from the cruise you know a little
bigger than when we left maybe a lot
bigger than when we left so 30 day we
lost chocolate I've never done anything
on my channel though fitness or weight
loss or any of that stuff well so we're
going to put it up but I'm not going to
lose my subscribers because I have the
top tens of regular the interest is a
regular the other series are regular so
I'm just searching for what is the
regular thing that you put up while you
do the other experimentation stuff well
what is the regular cut up I so far from
landing on my channel not red bar w
anything I mean it couldn't be like all
of it has potential the inspirational
videos were great the fear series was
good the the ask rich was good the the
you sharing your stuff when you came
over here and you were in the backyard
and we're filming you know your thoughts
on things you sharing your book that you
read all of them could be great it's
really much more about what you feel
like you want to share like what what
are you excited about from any of that
stuff and the fact that you haven't
continued means it's probably none of
them because you would have continued if
you felt so excited about them all right
often the same nah not it's not the
right vibe and so I just wonder if like
a like a rich confessional or something
might be a consistent theme where you're
just always you know I kind of have it
in my videos I'm always talking about
what I'm doing I'm always trying for
examples from what's happening in my
business in my life in the video so
people can kind of follow a lot
um I'm just wonder if that might make
sense the ritual is a national ourselves
like share your journey and end and I
think you might get a lot of love and
support the more you share what you're
worried about and scared about you'll
have people leaving comments trying to
help your suggestions ask questions and
that will give you motivation to see
that you're not in this alone other
people think in similar things yeah
comments are elastics I've experienced
better that my last video put up which
were more worried especially to give it
a name me kind of sharing well now but
yeah here it like you can and you know
that I'm okay with it getting all kinds
of nice comment on yeah and now that
seems to be the only thing that's I'm
doing my part up front of figuring out
to go with the heart on what you look
like a while I'm really know what a good
people I'm going to do whatever I feel
like I want to this moment whatever you
drawing it in so that drew me and kind
of talk about what's happening right now
and so kind of talk about that I don't
know what I put on you want to put on as
a video or as a series of video so I'm
just going to say that for now and it
just felt good or right to make a few
videos basically about that and I don't
know what the next thing will be might
just be whatever is up right now or what
I really don't know yet what it's gonna
be yeah I have a good eventually you hit
your stride eventually you'll find it
that this is what I love doing you get a
nice stretch with my the common thread
is going to be you through everything if
you look at my youtube channel how it's
changed all my videos used to just be
mean answering question what right and
now I only answer one question a week to
a week or do them all like in my Evan
video kind of thing um most of them are
questions anymore that i'm done i'm at
it it changes i change i didn't want to
just answer questions all the time i
wanted to shake it up
really my channels like such it's a it's
in such an infantile stage it's like
kind of gonna baby it it's like an not
even it's like a tiny embryo really
you're kind of my whatever like doesn't
even really matter what I do right now
cuz I'm still finding my thing and when
I find my thing naturally will grow so
right now it almost doesn't matter kind
of like a place to be created it's like
my little art piece that I could throw
paint on and see what I like or drop it
if I don't like it that's kind of how I
have it like right now yeah and it's
good i like it i like the experian
tation like that you've still tried to
be consistent even though you're not
consistent at one thing your lil the
assistant with now is timing that
something comes out of you that's the
only thing that consisting right now
right videos y yeah i think it's worth
experimenting i think it's worth trying
to see try try doing the confessionals
and see if that or whatever you want to
call it i'm writing confessionals but
confessionals makes it song makes it
sound like something just so that's a
little more consistent um so it's not
all over the place because otherwise you
have these playlists that people will
subscribe to and then they go through
the playlist and they're going to leave
the channel well I know as soon as it
might be to say it I'm I'm okay with it
like I used to be real concerned with
subscribers and numbers innocent bad but
I gave that up it doesn't really matter
at this point I know I want to do this
for whatever reason which is still a
mystery for me yeah but and it will
happen the wait will happen it will
happen it's times like I'm not concerned
if numbers anymore people drop out fine
it's all good people come on break it's
all good i'm making a video about this
about that whatever notes I want it to
be like already on the path and you
don't already you know cleared but it's
not and I'm not having an easy time
forcing it and I'm not gonna force it
anymore i'm just going to kind of ride
the wave and trust that it will work out
the way it's supposed to work
out yeah and I agree and I don't I don't
want any know what else to do with
myself and i'm at work on the outside I
choke myself out a long time ago it's
okay it's I mean you have to progress at
your own pace and I know I forced you
into it took a year to force you to just
do one video so it's great to see that
the progress of momentum I I do see you
be able to have a major impact on
people's lives with the message in your
talents and your skills I want I want it
to be exposed right wow you don't eh I
want it to be important I don't want it
to be like Oh which is 60 and still just
popping from something to another or not
like giving a good chance to to be
successful um and I want you I wanted to
lead to business not just like they want
to be what I right like I want it
yesterday I wanted to believe you the
business I want to I want to make an
impact with it already i want to have
that burning desire that excitement of
your day doing you know knowing what i'm
doing and that I'm doing the right thing
I want our to believe in so it's making
me nuts a little bit and it make me so
nuts for so long that I just decided to
surrender to it give it up and let what
comes come and that's why the
confessional started coming out because
like I was ready to just give it up like
it's like just forcing it isn't working
for me so what can you do if you can't
for sergey's got to be like water and
let it go see words well I'm and see I
think like those messages could be
really helpful for people are there's a
lot of people who are in the same
position as you and even if you don't
have the answers like I don't know what
I'm doing but i'm going to try a bunch
of stuff out like even that while
courage to jump into the unknown people
will be curious to see where you go with
it and will be inspired to want to do
something because a lot of people don't
have that courage they'll they'll remain
chained for the rest of their life right
so you may not think that you're special
and you made the guts is like I believe
I'm a failure everyone I'm doing my
channel sucks you know I have no no
consistency that what like all the
things that you say I'm small on nothing
but for a lot of people they haven't
even started right and they want to and
they you've already broken through so
many chains that most people still wear
and sharing where you're at and where
you're trying to go and the uncertainty
along the way um is powerful and will
help will help inspire people and that
could lead to a next the next shedding
of the skin and into that's what I think
too cuz you know I don't know what I'm
doing right now but I know it's going on
the right direction because things are
getting easier and simpler and they're
less significant than I care less it's
like stuff that was like inconsequential
but I made it big it's just started to
dissolve so and I actually I made a
video there that day if you saw yet I
put out there's basically pretty much
saying that you know I don't know what
the hell I'm doing right now but I'm
just gonna go with it and follow my
heart and all fleets right thing and
thanks for being on journey with me and
I got comments from other people saying
how they feel the same way and you know
it was really it was really nice to see
how you know I had thought I was all
alone and this confused not knowing what
the hell I want no I get like so many
people are the same way when they're
just grateful to have someone to say the
same thing so they feel like they're not
alone too it was really nice I love it
who knows where it'll go right so I know
it's gonna go somewhere special man
that's where it's gonna go it's good for
being so cool I'm doing I gotta hop off
for another call okay keep me posted for
those of for everybody watching I'll
leave riches channel in the description
so you can check them out and we'll talk
to to enrich let me know what I can come
to your headquarters again another
another session alright alright i'll let
you know next and I can help you shoot
it to fewer if your guys away ok cool
appreciate the offer we'll do it alright
thanks rich I've a better run by human